foreign
pop and K drama to K-Town America has
fallen in love with Korean culture that
includes cave food with its unique range
of spicy sauces this morning on the dish
Elizabeth Palmer takes us to rural South
Korea to meet a legend of the Korean
sauce world and her American guest who
is somewhat of a legend too
laughs
deep in the countryside row upon row of
handmade clay pots called ongi fill the
co-family's yard which is also
headquarters of the Korean traditional
food company
the seasons change here but little else
does nature sets the pace
sundo Ki is both founder and matriarch
today she has a guest from Washington
the American chef Johnny Sparrow for him
Mrs key has decided to lift the lid on
the Family's pride and joy soybeans
slowly fermenting with water and bamboo
salt
no wealth
these are the Magic ingredients that
anchor kisundo's line of signature
sauces and pastes it's like the perfect
combination of like sweet and savory and
oh well super aromatic
the Alchemy of unhurried fermentation
unlocks rich flavors in the family Zhang
that's the catch-all term for those
delicious dark soy sauces and earthy
Bean pastes that give Korean food its
range and pizzazz
is some of the very finest and Sparrow's
here to see how it's made
he's on something of an enforced break
after disaster struck last August his
michelin-starred restaurant reverie
burnt down does it hurt to think about
it now we lost like literally everything
so uh books knives wine everything it
was devastating and left him with a
stark choice there's two paths that I
could have taken the negative route that
probably would have taken me to a place
that I don't know where I would have
gone or where how I would have come back
or you know looking at it as an
opportunity to really reshape what I
want the restaurant to be reverie 2.0 is
poised to Rise From the Ashes one of my
investors said get the restaurant open
and then go to therapy
this is therapy of sorts exploring Korea
seeing tasting
and cooking up a storm with the
Australian Chef Joseph Lidgerwood at his
Michelin restaurant Yvette in Seoul it's
a time of reflection for a man who after
years of hard work and harder partying
has now started a family and clean up
his act giving up alcohol was a big deal
for you
yeah I think so because I've had a lot
of people ask how I did it how did you
Johnny Spiro just stopped drinking
because I had a I guess a little bit of
a reputation uh
I had a lot of fun but do I want to be
in my 50s hanging out at a bar with line
Cooks beers and shots lined up and just
being numb and not feeling anything the
answer was no yeah
these days sober he's up for anything
including washing the soybean blocks
called major
they're then wrapped in twists of straw
and hung to gather organisms from the
air to kick-start fermentation
there are no artificial ingredients here
and no shortcuts either
once the first Zhang of the new year is
done the Cole Family gathers to offer
rice cakes and wine to the god of the
clay pots Chul Jung and ask him to
protect the fermentation
Divine benevolence a deep respect for
tradition and sunoki's taste and
experience underpin this business which
she founded with her late husband in
1992.
now 74 she's been named Grand Master of
traditional food culture by the Korean
government
and she's agreed to show me how the
chili paste known as gochujang is made
it takes soy both ground and homemade
sauce plus rice malt syrup and chili
powder how did you know how much chili
to put in
she just put the right amount the right
amount okay I shouldn't have asked
it's been done like this for 370 years
she tells me and those are the products
we sell today
with one exception 14 years ago grand
master key suddenly went off-piste and
added local strawberries to her classic
gochujang it's a big step right because
you're messing with tradition here but
it was a hit at home and Stateside two
where Johnny Sparrow got his first taste
we tried it by itself at first and I
think we all just kind of stood there
silent because no one no one knew how to
describe it but the strawberry stuff was
like so complex and it just it just
lingers in like the most Pleasant of
ways Sparrow Incorporated it into
reverie's previous menu long before he
met its inventor
and today they're collaborating on a
fresh batch on the verge of exciting
challenges for him a new restaurant for
her a U.S sales office both inspired by
their reverence for craftsmanship family
and Fine Food
[Music]
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Elizabeth
Palmer in damyang South Korea
wow beautiful absolutely beautiful I
mean you really see the respect that
goes into every single little drop of
that I mean 370 years old for the oldest
I know and you know just the right
amount yeah no real recipe just
eyeballing what is okay so where what
are we tasting so I think what we have
here is that strawberry goju Jang that
uh that Elizabeth was talking about here
um and it's supposed to be sweet which
I've never had before sweet and spicy it
looks very good yes it's just the white
amount of spice if you ask me it's
delicious that's very good oh it is
spicy it has a kick to it which is why
the cucumber is also supposed to help
cool it down is that what that's there
for but yeah it's delicious